[Music]
foreign
night the escape window closing in Sudan
a Toronto professor's Journey ouch with
her three-year-old for myself it was a
surreal experience and why Canadians
still there might be stuck
revamped sex offender registry the
proposed added offenses to the list
CT scans have really been one of the
Miracles of modern medicine but with too
many comes a risk a new study linking
CTS with Childhood Cancer
this is my photograph we were situated
in a Westminster Abbey and a BC man's
Reflections on the Queen's coronation
ahead of the crowning of the new king
global national we are Nasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us we begin with breaking news
tonight two more Canadian flights have
departed Sudan according to defense
minister Anita Anand about 375 Canadians
have already been airlifted out of the
country since violent erupted two weeks
ago today but as Mackenzie gray reports
there are still Canadians waiting for
Rescue and it's becoming more
challenging to get them out
the Sudanese ceasefire seemingly falling
apart as the Air Force is sent in to try
and hunt down members of the rapid
support forces militia through thick
black smoke covering parts of cartoon
the nearly three weeks of fighting has
killed hundreds and left Millions inside
Sudan with limited food and water the
deteriorating conditions have also sent
foreign National scrambling As Time runs
out to flee the war-torn country we see
the window of opportunity at the what he
said not airport rapidly
deteriorating given the fighting that is
moving closer and closer that window
could close as soon as tonight according
to a source with direct knowledge of the
Canadian evacuation plan the defense
minister says there's another flight
scheduled to depart today but it could
be one of the last leaving the feds to
turn to plan B we continue to examine a
number of options to evacuate Canadians
including through Maritime assets and
overground Transport Canada already has
Naval capabilities near the port of
Sudan which has been a key location
other countries have used to evacuate
their citizens who are sent from Sudan
to Saudi Arabia on an arduous 24-hour
boat ride for myself it was a surreal
experience University of Toronto
Professor nisra element made the journey
with her three-year-old daughter and
elderly parents my father is almost 90.
um
and
um he didn't want to leave you know I
think for him I mean at some point he
told me listen I'm
you know
I would rather be buried at home
element's Journey to the port included a
12-hour bus ride from the capitol
through militia checkpoints and she had
to leave family members behind she was
visiting in cartoon I've had you know
family members killed during this time
um I've had several family members
injured um I don't know any Sudanese who
has not directly been impacted by this
the defense minister said there were
over 300 Canadians that have requested
help from the federal government to be
evacuated but what route they take out
of the country pharah is becoming less
clear
hmm yeah that's a good question that
root I mean the government did say mac
that they will make every effort to
bring Canadians home despite the public
sector strike happening right now which
does include some Foreign Affairs
employees the government has also said
that won't impact the Sudan situation
much but I want to talk to you about
that strike itself because we have new
information on the offer presented to
the union by Ottawa yesterday what have
we learned Mac yeah far the treasury
board announced this afternoon that the
offer that they presented the public
service and lines of Canada yesterday
was their final offer now they wouldn't
give any specific details but they did
say that presented a enhanced wage offer
which is one of the key sticking points
on this strike another one of the big
issues working from home which was also
touched on and the FEDS also made it
pretty clear far that they think there
should be a vote from the 155 000
members who were out on strike on
whether or not they should take this
deal now the union said they've received
the offer and again they're not
commenting on how the negotiations are
going or what's in it but by labeling
this the final offer from the feds it
certainly does increase the
probabilities that if the union doesn't
accept it the Liberals could bring in
Back To Work legislation and if that
happens the former Clerk of the privy
Council believes the House of Commons
would pass it it would be surprising and
somewhat shocking if the conservatives
used this to trigger an unnecessary 600
million dollar June election so I think
we can expect that Back To Work
legislation will pass
now the Liberals have been clear that
legislating the Striking public servants
back to work is their last resort and it
does seem like there is some hope that a
deal can get done because both sides far
are still negotiating through the full
weekend and we'll be watching very
closely thank you for that Mackenzie
gray in Ottawa
to the war in Ukraine now where there
were multiple attacks on
russian-controlled regions today in
Crimea an apparent drone strike on the
port city of sevastopol set fire to a
fuel Depot according to its Russian
installed Governor there were no reports
of any injuries and in the
russian-controlled city of donesque
there was more shelling there a day
after Russian officials claimed a rocket
strike killed seven civilians Russia is
blaming Ukraine for all the attacks so
Kiev has claimed no responsibility
newly proposed changes to the national
sex offender registry are expected to
satisfy the Supreme Court after it was
determined last year that some
recommendations went too far but as
Erica Vela reports some say this
registry revamp doesn't go far enough
sexual offenses are amongst the most
heinous and degrading forms of violence
in an effort to combat those offenses
the federal government is backed from
the drawing board with new changes to
Bill S12 with the hopes to strengthen
Canada's national sex offender registry
under the proposed changes serious child
sexual offenders and repeat sexual
offenders would be registered
automatically all other sexual offenders
must also be registered unless they can
prove they pose no risk to the community
in addition the government is also
expanding the list of offenses if
someone non-consensually shares intimate
images and participates in extortion
their name could be added to the
national sex offender registry the
information is not public and will only
be accessible to law enforcement some
Advocates have raised concerns that
Wednesday's announcement won't change
much at all I guess my question would be
what do we want people to do with that
um you know I people don't know
um what to do next how however some
experts say the registry will be more of
a tool for police it won't actually
prevent a sex crime from happening it
allows them in an immediate shorthand
way of being able to identify who it
could possibly be that's already on the
registry if the intention is to protect
communities Spencer says more can be
done to educate people on sex crimes we
could be educating the public about how
sexual uh crime sex crimes happen and
that's a front-end thing that would
require massive levels of investment by
the government Global News has reached
out to several provinces about the
proposed amendments all said they were
carefully reviewing the changes
publication Bans are also addressed in
the government's updated plan with
judges now being required to ask
prosecutors about whether or not the
victim would like to see a publication
ban imposed and if the victim would like
to receive ongoing updates about their
case even after sentencing the bill
still needs to go through the House of
Commons before becoming law pharah
Erica Vella reporting thanks Erica a
recent rise in violent crime has
Canadians concerned some alarming
attacks were carried out by violent
repeat offenders police associations
have been urging Ottawa to tighten bail
reform for months our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson spoke with the
public safety Minister Marco Mendocino
on the topic for the West block this
week here's a look at just part of that
conversation
let's talk about bail reform another big
topic with the rise in violent crime
which has been over 30 percent since
your government took over in 2015.
there's a lot of concern about this
people are worried about taking the bus
or the subway they're worried in their
communities and one of the things that's
been identified in your government has
talked about is concerns about bail
conditions for repeat violent offenders
you've promised to do something about
that I think that was about a month ago
I haven't seen anything new will there
be legislation before the end of the
session on bail reform the short answer
is yes and I can tell you a little bit
about bail because as you know I've
worked on the front lines of the
Criminal Justice System we're committed
to dealing with this through reforms to
our bail laws including focusing on
repeat violent offenders and I share the
concerns about the recent Spate of
violence particularly in some larger
Urban centers like Toronto Vancouver
Calgary people need to be able to go
from point A to point B whether it's to
work or to play or to socialize safely
including on public transit system but
it's not just bail reform we also need
to make investments in law enforcement
this is a government that has put nearly
a billion dollars into supporting law
enforcement we'll have more to say about
that in the not too distant future but
we also need to address the social
determinants of gun crime and this is
where the Liberal Party stands itself in
a separate life from the conservatives
we believe that you've got to increase
the capacity of local organizations on
the ground when it comes to Mental
Health Services this is work I'm doing
in partnership with Minister Bennett the
first ever Federal minister of mental
health Affairs we've got to go after the
root causes of crime so that we can stop
tragedy and loss before it occurs
see Mercedes full interview with the
public safety Minister tomorrow right
here on global
there is more financial turmoil in the
U.S tonight sources are telling several
media organizations that Federal
Regulators are racing to seize and sell
the troubled First Republic Bank before
financial markets open on Monday the
effort comes after first Republic shares
tumbled 75 percent over the last week
when the bank is closed customers have
withdrawn more than half of its deposits
Bloomberg reports the U.S Federal
Deposit Insurance Corps has asked Banks
to submit final bids for First Republic
by Sunday if the San francisco-based
lender falls into receivership it would
be the third U.S Bank to collapse since
March
and there are some worrying signs
surrounding one of this country's
largest banks the Toronto Dominion Bank
or TD now has the dubious distinction of
being the most shorted Bank stock in the
world in other words more investors are
betting that its stock price will drop
and gaviola has more on why TD is in
their crosshairs and whether that spells
trouble for the rest of Canada's banking
sector
TD Bank has become the most shorted Bank
stock in the world a reflection of fears
about how sound the financial sector is
investors are somewhat pessimistic on
the financial sector right now just
given that we see so much trouble in
housing markets what makes TD a Target
its exposure to Canadian real estate and
the American banking sector there's also
its high price plan to acquire U.S
Regional Bank First Horizon investors
are worried that TD is no longer getting
a very good deal short selling is when
an investor borrows a stock and sells it
on the market planning to buy it back
later for less money short sellers bet
on and profit from a drop in the stock
price it has a high risk reward appeal
as it can make you a lot of money if
you're right but you stand to lose a lot
of money if things don't go your way in
fact your losses are unlimited because
there's no telling how high the share
price can go it's not like going long in
the stock market where the most it can
lose is the amount you invested to buy
stock NOW bets against TD have been on
the rise the most recent data shows
short positions on TD jumped to more
than 6 billion dollars last week
many analysts aren't too concerned about
TD though it is a large Diversified
well-funded Bank closely watched by
Canadian Regulators the situation is not
as dire as as some of these short sales
might believe you might see actually the
bank stock run higher and quicker some
believe TD shares could actually climb
causing what's known as a short squeeze
a recent example happened when retail
investors banded together and drove the
price of GameStop which was heavily
shorted by hedge funds higher many of
the funds panicked as the price of
GameStop soared increasing their losses
they quickly bought shares of GameStop
further propelling the price higher I'm
not particularly worried about TD Bank
but maybe hedge funds betting against
the bank should be concerned and the
viola Global News Toronto
risky radiation and our kids coming up
the number of CT scans that could double
the risk of cancer in children
a new study is underscoring potential
risks that come with repeated CT scans
its use in children has been on the rise
in recent decades given how much doctors
can learn from these type of scans but
as Catherine Ward reports data shows us
that repeated use on Children and Youth
can increase their risk of cancer
experts have been aware for some time
that CT scans are something to be used
judiciously when treating a patient CT
scans have really been one of the
Miracles of modern medicine but like any
test they do have their own risks Dr
James Whitlock says the cost benefit
analysis is a constant conversation
among Medical Teams especially when it
comes to treating children CT scans use
ionizing radiation ionizing radiation
can damage DNA and lead to a small but
real increased risk of subsequent
development of cancers for some CT scans
a child might also need sedation
patients who undergo repeated episodes
of sedation may have increased risk for
cognitive outcomes there's also the risk
of reactions to the contrast material
that may be given with the CT scan a new
study out of Taiwan looked at data from
thousands of children fighting
intracranial tumors leukemia or lymphoma
between 2000 and 2013. they found that
those who had four or more CT scans had
more than double the risk of developing
some forms of cancer this study really
confirms what we've we've known for
quite a while but also frames it in a
way that is a bit more easily digestible
in terms of you know four or more CT
scans doubles the risk of intracranial
tumors for example so it makes it a bit
more accessible to most people
radiologist Dr John Donlon says it's
important for Medical Teams to look at
all treatment possibilities if a child
needs to have a study that involves
ionizing radiation number one we ask
ourselves is there any other way of
getting that information using a
different modality such as MRI for
example because MRI does not have any
ionizing radiation at all and for
families to keep track of the care
that's been received including the
amount of radiation which is a lot more
telling because we know basically what
some of the thresholds are that if you
reach a certain amount of radiation
exposure that your risk goes up kind of
a proxy for that is the number of CT
scans but as a physician who Works in
Radiology what's much more interesting
to me is the actual dose that the
patient receives with each of those
studies Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
I had food banks are springing up at
universities why Canadian students are
struggling to cope with post-secondary
life in a new way
by now Canadians know all too well that
total inflation is taking is the cost of
everything from groceries to gas goes up
it's also posing some especially unique
challenges for students learning in this
country they're already stressed about
their academics and paying for their
tuition but now they also have to deal
with the rise in cost of living Alicia
dross has more
cost of groceries is a huge one cost of
gas too like all Canadians University
students are being hit hard by inflation
and while April exam season is now
wrapping up the financial pressure made
it extra challenging for many this year
I'm at school full-time and then having
two separate part-time jobs doesn't
leave a ton of time for stuff like
studying stuff like exam prep graduate
student Shirey Lee feels the same
instead of focusing on school she spent
much of the Year seeking extra tutoring
opportunities to cover costs I live on
my stipend for my Master's Degree and
that looking at the inflationary right
now and the expense of living the
stipend does not cover the cost at all
in addition to the rising cost of living
there's also the rising cost of tuition
in Canada on average tuition has
increased 22.5 percent over the last
decade during the same time entrance
scholarships have largely remained
unchanged most scholarships are
donor-based and therefore can't be
adjusted to inflation but bursaries can
and many universities are doing just
that McGill increased its average annual
Aid to students by 45 percent since
2018. Western University has also
increased their bursary program several
times over the past three years to
accommodate increases to the cost of
living and for those struggling
throughout the year food banks have
sprung up at universities across the
country like this one at Dalhousie which
has seen an increase in students over
the past few months so predominantly we
had a really big group of international
students with you know a smaller group
from domestic but it's lately as we're
getting a lot of domestic students and
their stories are all the same it's like
I thought I could make it through
I thought I could do this as another
school year comes to an end the focus
now for many students turns to summer
employment to save up as much as they
can for next year Alicia dross Global
News Halifax
[Music]
if long memories ahead of the crowning
of her son
the British town of Aldershot is getting
the full Royal Treatment hundreds of
soldiers began rehearsals for the king's
coronation Charles will be crowned at
London's Westminster Abbey one week from
today in a ceremony with Traditions
dating back 1 000 years
it was nearly 70 years ago that the last
coronation took place for Queen
Elizabeth II and seven decades later the
memories are still crystal clear for one
BC resident who was there in person
Jasmine King reports
participated in the four Nation itself
and the naval review later in Portsmouth
ahead of the crowning of a new king Carl
zennon of West Kelowna is taking a trip
back in time 70 years to be exact to the
coronation of Queen Elizabeth II when he
was there in person this is Nelson
British Columbia
on 16 years old and then all of a sudden
being selected to represent British
Columbia
and as part of a 12C Cadets xanan
traveled to Halifax with the Canadian
sea Cadet contingent where he boarded
the hmcs Magnificent to sail across the
Atlantic days ahead of his trip zannon
was given a camera to document the
journey that was a gift by the local
group black and white of course and um
and and so that it got me interested in
that subject xanan captured pictures on
board the carriers at famous landmarks
and on the day of the coronation where
he stood outside when the queen passed
by on the gold State coach this is my
photograph I we were situated in
Westminster Abbey we saw the queen
arrive and we saw her leave it was
really really impressive the details
that they went to not only for us but
all the things that they were doing so
it was quite an adventure zanin hasn't
spoke much about his trip until recently
at local Diamond and Platinum Jubilee
celebrations where he gave a speech
about the queen he says he didn't think
it would be this long between
coronations and the parades the details
that went into it and we have no 70 plus
years later
and I hope King Charles III is going to
get the same treatment and I wish him
well zannon says he didn't appreciate
the once in a lifetime trip at the time
but remembers his commanding officer
telling him to savor the moment he was
so excited that I got selected and you
know I just didn't appreciate
what was coming and he could Envision
that and that an example of the
difference in expectation King Charles
III's coronation is on May 6 and xanan
says he'll be tuned in to see every
moment Jasmine King Global News West
Kelowna
what an opportunity Global News will
have special coverage of the king's
coronation on May 6th Donna Friesen will
be live in London at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M
Pacific right here on global
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and
tonight's year Canada is a look at
Toronto Maple Leafs faithful in downtown
Toronto hoping tonight's the night they
make it to round two of the NHL playoffs
and on the other side of the country
soon will be the orange and blue with
High Hopes the Edmonton Oilers also
Advance later tonight go Canada until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
foreign
[Music]